all right well for this week's classic
interview we are going to go back to my
interview with Kevin Sinha from November
of 2015 at the time we didn't know how
the relationship of the David Pakman
show to coffee would explode not only do
we now have our own to coffee lines the
drip and espresso coffee lines at david
pakman.com slash gear but Pat almost I
would I would say almost lost your
reputation over what we are now calling
the Keurig Salman's canceled the show it
almost actually pulled the show off the
air yeah hard to believe as it may be so
now with those new revelations we can
watch my interview with Kevin Senate
from November of 2015 with a fresh
perspective is what I'm calling it let's
check it out I'm joined today by Kevin
Senate author of the art and craft of
coffee and the creator and host of
coffee con the consumer coffee festival
it's so great to have you on you know I
think a lot of people drink coffee
many people have lots of questions about
coffee and one that I want to jump right
into is about Fairtrade coffee
what is Fairtrade exactly and is it is
it really that fair well the the concept
is a great concept and the idea is
everyone in you know the certain region
I guess are regions the wrong word
that's too large let's say everyone in a
neighborhood pulls their coffee together
and the idea is that they you've got a
better a better deal and there's there's
a third party involved called a
Fairtrade freighter
I guess and that person is supposed to
oversee the deal so that it's good for
the farmers and good for the people who
are buying the coffee who are Roasters
the challenge with it anybody is that
well first of all there's always a
challenge in the coffee business I'm
sorry to say that sometimes introducing
a third party in the middle increases
the risk that the farmers don't get paid
rather than lessens it so that's
obviously not
the majority of cases but but that's one
factor that I hear from farmers
occasionally the other thing is ideally
if the farmer is there's a better deal
for farmers and that's the direct trade
and that's where they actually sell
directly to the Roasters it seems like
they have a better chance of making all
the money and they get more you a better
deal for them so that's kind of you'll
hear direct trade Roasters touting that
so I would say direct trade is ideal on
the other hand a farmer has to be a
certain size usually to get a direct
trade deal yeah I recently spoke to a
roaster Oh does the direct trade route
and they said you know the the the
prices they gave me were that fair trade
is really only raising the amount that
is paid to the farmer from in the low
dollar and change range to the high
dollar and change range and that some
piece of that is actually going to the
third party organization as you
mentioned that apparatus that manages
the fair trade status so that it is it
is sort of a label that they don't feel
actually tells us very much about how
fair the price is being paid are to put
it in show business terms it's a manager
a great manager gets you more gigs and
and and you your career does better and
and and they negotiate a great deal for
you on the other hand if you're a farmer
that is capable of negotiating your own
deals you're probably better off with
directory okay all this makes sense
let's now talk about coffee and health
coffee and health seems to be studied
endlessly coffee is sometimes great for
you sometimes it's bad for you then it's
good as long as it's two to three cups a
day but not more than four or just one
cup of coffee a day is really great but
beyond that we have no idea how do you
as a coffee expert sort of navigate all
of the different opinions and and
so-called studies about the health
impacts of coffee yeah III I'm actually
my background is in science my
background is history so I I tend to
approach it more from a historic point
of view that coffee drinkers on average
live as long or longer than non-drinkers
so I think coffee is at worst inert and
yes once in a while you'll hear some
claims about anti viral and different
effects [ __ ] you that may be good for
you using modern I guess health concerns
and and and looks at studies that are
done however I'm always really I'm
really resistant to reluctant to
consider coffee itself a so-called
health drink hmm it's just it seems like
it's got some good qualities on the
other hand people have to be careful a
what they put into their coffee which
can change those things and be what they
have along with their coffee which is
probably you know something coffee seems
to be forever sold with things that are
sweet and other delicious may not be
considered right if you're having a half
dozen bear claws with your cup of coffee
that will have an impact if that's your
but what you're doing every time what's
the hot thing right now I mean people at
homes like to have their French presses
Turkish coffee with the grounds in it is
being served at more and more places and
and more countries around the world
although it doesn't seem to be too
popular in the US so far I was at a
place yesterday that had the pour over
method which to me just seemed like
you're dripping the coffee from six
inches instead of one inch I didn't
totally understand what the different
with difference was what's it what's the
popular thing now in the coffee world
well I'd say the pour over is that is
the drink of the week and and there
there is a difference by the way I'm
going to defend or over a little bit
please the the mr. coffee pour over is
is it is an attempt a crude attempt I
might add to automate what was a manual
method and and there are the benefit of
the hand pour is that you can see and
time things so all the grounds get
nicely explained
and the timing and everything so that
you don't put too much water in because
then there's a lot of water in there
that's cooling and what you want to do
is just have enough water that it keeps
all the grounds covered and you do get I
think a significantly better cup now as
I say this there are automatic methods
that are now improving and getting for
flexible and even programmable so that
they're better
emulating will be what what a great
barista could do but so far I think the
wins all right so now there's there's
two areas of big controversy around
coffee
one is Keurig machines the other is
chain coffee places like Dunkin Donuts
and Starbucks let's talk about the
second one first our Dunkin Donuts and
Starbucks providing good coffee
the when I I've completely stopped going
to those places because I just find that
there is nothing at all redeeming about
ordering a cup of coffee at Starbucks or
Dunkin Donuts I prefer the local
mom-and-pop style coffee places I prefer
a local person for non taste reasons it
is to do with the same reason I will
always call a contractor in the local
paper instead of a chain for almost
anything that's just my personal bias
but I definitely have to say there's a
difference between the two chains while
Dunkin Donuts does a lighter roast I
prefer a lighter roast personally
generally do Starbucks actually does buy
some of the copies that we're talking
about that are Fairtrade direct trade
they have shown a a better social
consciousness the both for their growers
and sustainability here at home which I
think it's oftentimes not good you know
they do try to provide things in place
so on a social justice point of view I
see a dude a big difference between
Starbucks and and Dunkin Donuts
certainly Starbucks it's interesting now
after the clots rather the taste I I
would agree a Starbucks is chase
automation to agree that you really
don't get best a brief that can do at in
the average Starbucks experience and you
don't get and that roast is so dark
there are some coffees where I feel like
wow they roasted off that distinctive
flavor and of course Starbucks is
inextricably linked to these Frappuccino
and and blended with chocolate syrup and
whipped cream and all this other stuff
that has become quote coffee over the
last 10 or so years is that just
absolutely crazy to you that coffee has
become these six hundred calorie drinks
or is it hey to each their own you know
this is a middle ground honest and and I
I'm going to choose a path that's a
little bit controversial on both sides
on the one hand if you're drinking
coffee that is what the caramel
macchiato that I have once I ordered a
macchiato and a macchiato is actually a
is supposed to be at least originally
was a espresso with a little bit of milk
in it it's perfect for someone like me I
don't mind a little bit face especially
in the morning sure and with the coffee
but but I got this thing head was pretty
sweetened and they had all kinds of
syrup we so Martian I don't care for is
it barely it's barely coffee certainly
it's coffee flavored and certainly I do
believe I'm I believe that consumer
should be able to decide what they want
for having a coffee legislation no
certainly not but definitely on the
other end some of my friends and we get
a lot of these people like a copy con to
I love them of course they buy tickets
but but they're there they have an
attitude that no one can have anything
in their coffee I suspect these people
were we're into chocolate they beat
baker's chocolate right yeah it's the
idea that you're affecting the sanctity
and purity of the coffee if you put even
a drop of sugar or a little bit of cream
in it which which seems crazy in the
very little time we have left I want to
get your thoughts on Keurig
I think Keurig is a disaster
environmentally I think Keurig is a
disaster in terms of the coffee quality
and I think that it is incredibly
overpriced on a price per pound basis
when you look at Keurig what do you
think about Keurig type machines well
the cost itself i'ma go backwards the
cost is is ridiculous I mean you can get
you can drink the coffee I'm gonna tell
your audience you can drink the coffee I
drink and I buy the most expensive
coffee there is and I am you are paying
as much if not more than I am
and you're getting kind of the probably
the lowest tier of at least specialty
cloth sure meaning it's not great a
second of all as far as the
environmental aspect the original
product it's is horrible and inexcusable
shocking that it came a company that
used to have such a great reputation the
specialty coffee business like Green
Mountain the third thing however there's
a cure for that there are some products
known even Malita makes a 100%
recyclable price and just seek that out
do a little research
everyone's got googled out so you don't
even have to buy up a book of pain or
something to find out there are some
response products out there that reduce
the waste the third thing is the taste
the taste is think about where we were
we have machines that took 14 minutes to
make a pot of coffee people throw out
most of it hopefully I don't know about
the health effects of that but it
certainly didn't taste the carrot
machine if anything under its tracks it
doesn't have as much bitterness
generally however it is inherently stale
and that is a problem you've gotta pay
to be a member of kind of our club
ideally want to grind
beats throwing up beans that are exhibit
in two weeks
let's go a month just to make it doable
but but that's that's really compared to
care of me pups that are they're
probably roasted a year ago we needs to
be at a supermarket
yeah it's a big difference spot on spot
on analysis Kevin how many cups of
coffee a day do you drink out of
curiosity tree
I actually drink in the morning I
usually have one after lunch and I have
one in the evening because I do a late
shift where I always bright at night I
like bright at night it's quiet
all right Kevin sent it four cups of
coffee a day you heard it from him right
here check out the art and craft of
coffee and check out coffee con the
consumer coffee festival Kevin thanks
for being on with us David